en la ciudad de nueva york en un día
soleado similar al de hace 20 años eeuu
rinde homenaje a las 3000 víctimas del
ataque que conmocionó al mundo
se dio inicio a la ceremonia a las 8 46
de la mañana momento en el que el primer
avión secuestrado fue estrellado contra
la torre norte del world trade center
ese 11 de septiembre de 2001 el actual
mandatario joe biden y los ex
presidentes barack obama y bill clinton
se unieron a los familiares de las
víctimas para marcar un minuto de
silencio
y mi memoria se remonta a ese terrible
día en el que parecía que un espectro
maligno había descendido sobre nuestro
mundo pero también fue un momento en el
que muchas personas actuaron por encima
de lo normal empezando por las
tripulaciones de los vuelos como sara
water
después los familiares comenzaron a
recitar los nombres de las casi 3.000
víctimas mortales un ritual anual que se
prolongó durante varias horas
llamé a jubilados
en una ceremonia más pequeña a altos
mandos militares rindieron homenaje a
los muertos del pentágono prometiendo
continuar con su legado de protección de
la nación el ex presidente george bush
que estaba en el cargo cuando se
produjeron los atentados asistió por su
parte al acto conmemorativo desde
shanksville donde se estrelló el vuelo
93 de united airlines
en las semanas y meses que siguieron al
11-s me sentí orgulloso de dirigir a un
pueblo impresionante resistente y unido
hablando de la unidad de eeuu esos días
parecen haber quedado atrás una fuerza
maligna parece actuar en nuestra vida
cotidiana convirtiendo cada desacuerdo
en una disputa y cada discusión en un
choque de culturas
falsos
en dos décadas los atentados yihadistas
más mortíferos de la historia están ya
anclados en la memoria colectiva de eeuu
pero el dolor de las familias de las
víctimas y de los supervivientes sigue
siendo agudo